we finished off the last video entering
into the Great Depression it wasn't just
a depression for the u.s. it was a
depression for the world but I want to
back up a little bit
because I forgot to mention a very
important fact that's hugely important
to the rest of us history in the
twentieth century and that's what
happened in 1917 actually during World
War one and that's the Bolshevik
Revolution the Russian Empire was
overthrown by the Bolsheviks and it
became the Soviet Union and it which you
probably know was a communist state and
it became the United States arch enemy
over the rest of well not over the rest
of but after nearly I guess the second
half of the 20th century so with that
out of the way I just want to make sure
you know that Russia is now the Soviet
Union let's fast-forward back through
the Great Depression and probably the
one point when we're doing this very
high-level overview that's of interest
and as you can see even though the focus
of this series of videos is on US
interest what's happening in the rest of
the world starting to become much more
important because the u.s. is starting
to become this really serious global
actor and so in 1933 so this is right in
the middle right in the middle of this
global depression and Germany was
especially hit hard especially because
of all the damage done by World War one
and the war reparations and all the rest
you have Hitler coming to power as
Chancellor of Germany and it's
interesting to note that it was actually
he came to power in a democratic process
Chancellor of Germany is analogous to
prime minister of other countries and so
essentially he was ruling a coalition
his the Nazis his party did not have the
majority but they were able to control
this coalition although it was a very
weak one but what they were good at is
intimidating and rigging elections and
all the rest and so over the course of
the rest of the 30s essentially the
Nazis consolidated power until we get to
1939 and the rest of the world was you
know they would kind of watch Hitler he
was consolidating power Turnagain he
came in democratically but he was
essentially consolidating power under
himself turning it into a dictatorship
he was militarizing Germany people
started to get concerned but they all
kind of wanted to they had the doctrine
of appeasement hey you know let's just
let's just kind of you know not
two angry and maybe he won't start
anything too bad but in 1939 Germany
invades Poland invades Poland this is
kind of viewed as the one event that the
kind of the straw that breaks the
camel's back so to speak and so it
begins World War two so this is the
beginning of World War two and initially
it's between I guess the if you think
about the great powers that initially
get involved it is the British Empire
and the Soviet Union France is involved
it quickly gets overrun by the Nazis and
what happens is is that the US for it
wasn't like the situation with World War
one where the u.s. was trying to stay
neutral the US had recognized especially
FDR Franklin Delano Roosevelt he had
recognized that Hitler that Hitler was
an aggressor that he was I guess from
from FDR's part of you definitely in the
wrong here so even from the beginning of
World War two the u.s. did help support
did help support the Allies support the
Allies so it would send arms and any
other type of assistance when Japan and
Italy joined on the side of Germany the
u.s. embargoed oil to Japan the u.s. was
an exporter of oil to Japan and you
could imagine Japan did not produce a
lot of its own oil and oil is super
important when you're trying to run a
war machine so that didn't make Japan
too happy
so you fast forward to 1941 and you have
Japan bombing Pearl Harbor so until this
point us kind of played a an on direct
role it definitely supported the Allies
it did what it could echo na mcclee and
by providing military aid but did not
actively participate in the fighting but
then December 7th 1941 the Japanese bomb
our bombed the US the US Pacific Fleet
at Pearl Harbor and that's that whole
interesting debate because or discussion
because it was lucky for the u.s. that
most a lot of the Pacific Fleet was not
there but it was obviously this kind of
this thing that would that convinced the
US public that it was that World War two
was worth joining so in 1941 because of
Pearl Harbor the u.s. enters the war
and it enters the war in both arenas
both in Europe and in the Pacific and
then you fast forward it goes against
the Italians in North Africa and then
you fast forward to 1944 it actually
enters it actually enters into the fight
in mainland Europe this is the invasion
of Normandy this is d-day June 6 1944 if
you've ever seen Saving Private Ryan it
starts with this and it's probably you
know I've never been in a I've never
stormed a beach but I can imagine that's
probably the the most realistic
reenactment of what it was like to storm
the beach at Normandy but you fast
forward to 1945 and eventually the the
especially between the Soviet and the US
or I should say all of the Allied forces
they were able to I guess win the
European front of world war two and and
then you fast forward till the end of
that year Japan was still kind of
fighting pretty ferociously and so the
US and you know this is once again I
could make many videos of this we can
debate the ethical implications of this
but the u.s. it develops the atomic bomb
ignites one over Hiroshima and then a
few days later one over Nagasaki and
that essentially ends World War two and
so the outcome of World War two is you
have two remaining superpowers you have
the Soviet Union you have the Soviet
Union and you have the United States and
what happens after that is that you have
the Cold War these two huge powers the
Soviet Union is this is this communist
country it's obviously trying to create
this communist fear of influence a lot
of Eastern Europe was falling under
Soviet sway the United States not a
communist country a very capitalist
country you can imagine and this is
something that gets confused a lot the
Soviet Union was communist and it was
totalitarian communism and democracy
aren't necessarily things that go
against each other but the Soviet Union
had had neither a capitalist system nor
democracy was it was both communist and
totalitarian and when I when I say
communist I'm talking about
no private wealth the state really owned
all resources the United States on the
hand other hand was hugely capitalist
and you could imagine many people the
United States did not want any of this
communism business
to kind of come come to us so you have
this major battle that never really
erupts into direct conflict between the
Soviet Union United States it's always
done through through proxies through
people who that the United States or the
Soviet Union is acting on the behalf or
who are acting on the behalf of the
United States or Soviet Union but you
have the Cold War beginning and it's
called the Cold War because it wasn't a
hot war the United States and the Soviet
Union never really fired bullets at each
other instead they supported they
supported other parties that would fire
bullets at the Soviet Union or the
Soviet Union would support other parties
that would fire bullets at the United
States and for the United States it was
all about stopping communism it was all
about preventing you know this domino
theory that if one country in a region
would fall to communism that other
countries would so the United States
became a bit paranoid or maybe it was
justified either way it was very
concerned about the spread of communism
and the first time that this really gets
tested in 1950 is an interesting year
because this is the first time obviously
the u.s. had nuclear weapons as of 1945
but in 1950 the Soviet Union tested its
first nuclear weapon so now the Cold War
is trying to get very serious both of
these adversaries can now nuke each
other if they wanted to and also in 1950
you have Korea and Korea before World
War two so that's a very small depiction
of Korea it was a Japanese colony but
obviously Japan had now lost and so
after World War two it was split between
an area North Korea which was influenced
by the Russians and South Korea which
was influenced by the United States and
it was split along the 38th parallel I
know this is a super small diagram we'll
go into more detail when we do detailed
videos about the Korean War but in 1950
you have the North Koreans invaded the
south so it started the Korean War the
u.s. sent troops the North Koreans had
China on their side the Chinese army the
Soviets were also supplying them but at
the end of the day in 1943 you
fast-forward it ends up being a little
bit of a stalemate because the end
result was is that the original 38th
parallel border gets I guess reinstated
but that was the first real conflict of
Cold War and notice there were never US
or Russian or I shouldn't say Russian US
or Soviet troops directly firing at each
other the people who are the US were
firing were at war with the North Korean
and the Chinese troops but they were
kind of proxies for the Soviet Union and
at the same time as you can imagine
because you have these two adversaries
these two technically sophisticated
adversaries they both had they both had
nuclear weapons it became very
interesting on who can kind of dominate
space so you have this kind of space
race developing in 1957 the Soviets are
able to are able to launch the first
artificial satellite around the earth
this is Sputnik one over here Sputnik
one some people think the first Sputnik
is the one that had the dog in it no
that came a few months later that was
Sputnik two actually had the picture of
the dog here but the dog eventually dies
but it was alive for a little bit in
orbit so that gets everyone freaked out
the u.s. responds that in 1961 you have
Yuri Gagarin he's the first person in
space first human being in space he
returns safely we eventually get up
there or the United States eventually
gets up there as well and then you fast
forward all the way to 1969 the u.s. is
the first to be on the moon so you have
the space race that's you know the two
countries are really trying to one-up
each other and at the same time that
that's happening you have and I bring
this up just because so much happened
during his presidency in 1960 you have
John F Kennedy
you have John F Kennedy being elected
kind of in the heart the heart of the
Cold War not you know the other
interesting thing is he was the first
Catholic president which was you know
people questioned whether well it that
by itself was interesting but was really
interesting in his short presidency and
I think you might know that he only had
really it he actually became president
in 61 this is an error he was elected in
60 but he became president in 61 he had
a very short presidency was assassinated
in 63 but a lot happened in that short
presidency in 1957 right before he
became president you had oh sorry not
1957 let me get my years right in 1959
you had the Cuban Revolution Cuba became
communist Fidel Castro takes over
it becomes communist so you can imagine
the the Americans didn't like a
communist state so close to our own
borders so in nineteen in 1961 we
support some X Cubans or some some Cuban
exiles to try to invade Cuba and that
also can be a whole topic for another
video
in what you know there's debates between
the CIA and the Kennedy administration
of who was to blame for it being such a
failure but it was a failure so it was a
huge embarrassment to the United States
and total and and from the the
revolutionaries point of view I should
you know the communist revolutionaries
point of view they kind of viewed this
as solidifying their hold of Cuba showed
that they could they could fend off
counterfeiting
and then you have in 1962 we have these
spy planes and we see that the Soviets
are starting to put these ballistic
missiles in Cuba which really freaks the
United States out because these
ballistic missiles could reach any part
of the United States
we actually had similar ones in parts of
Europe and Turkey but we didn't like
these things here so we essentially use
our Navy to I would say blockade the
anymore arms shipments to the Soviet
Union so Kennedy really has this kind of
standoff with the Soviet Union during
the Cuban Missile Crisis in 1962 and
most people believe that this was the
closest that the United States and the
Soviet Union ever got to actually having
a war and which would probably turned
into a nuclear war but the standoff of n
chily got resolved the the Soviet Union
agreed to remove their missiles
well one not send any more missiles and
dismantled the ones that they had
already set up and and this wasn't
publicly stated at the time but the
United States also agreed to do the same
thing for our missiles that were pointed
at the Soviet Union to remove those from
Turkey so the world kind of at least you
know at that point in time had avoided
kind of a mutually assured destruction
the whole time that this is happening
remember the United States is paranoid
and maybe justifiably so paranoia
usually means worried when there's not a
cause but maybe justifiably worried
about the spread of communism
you have a situation where in Vietnam
you have a Vietnam which is right about
right about let me make sure I get me
circle the right country you have in
Vietnam
you have the Communists come to power in
North Vietnam this was formerly a French
colony the US right from the get-go in
1950 starts sending advisers to aid the
the anti communists in South Vietnam in
Kennedy's administration the amount of
advisors and I should probably put that
in quotes because these advisors started
becoming much more involved really grew
and until in 1965 the United States
started sending its actual you know
official combat troops to fight in
Vietnam and you fast forward that all
the way to 1975 and the reason why this
is significant other than this being the
one of the more recent major Wars the
United States has been in it's the first
war that the United States kind of
unambiguously lost in 1975 the last the
last the last presence of the United
States left and essentially Saigon which
was the capital of South Vietnam fell to
the Communists so I'll leave you there
and we're now essentially in modern
history you know at least at least from
my point of view because I was born not
too long after that anyway hopefully you
found that interesting
let me oh I couldn't found the stop
button there you go